welcome to simply learns back
propagation and gradient descent my name
is Richard Kirchner with these simply
learn team that's wwm p.m. get certified
get ahead and when we're talking about
back propagation and gradient descent
we're talking neural networks so we
talked about the neural network this is
a simple nor network which must be
trained to recognize handwritten
alphabets a B and C and you can see here
we have our input coming in in this case
we'll look at the letter A written out
on a 28 by 28 pixels so the handwritten
outfits are presented as images of 28 by
28 pixels and that image comes in in
this case we have 784 neurons that's 28
times 28 and the initial prediction is
made using random weights assigned to
each channel and so we have our forward
propagation as you see here so each node
is then their values are added up and
ended up and so on going across and our
network predicts the input to be B with
the probability of 0.5 the predicted
probabilities are compared against the
actual probabilities and the error is
calculated so the error is simply the
actual minus predicted and you can see
here where we know it's not C so it's a
minus 2 we know it's not B so it's a
minus 0.5 but we do know that it is a a
so we go ahead and just that by 0.6 the
magnitude indicates the amount of change
while the sign indicates an increase or
decrease in the weights the information
is transmitted back through the network
so here comes our back propagation
weights throughout the network are
adjusted in order to reduce the loss in
prediction so if we look at this setup
right here here comes our error
in this case point 6 minus 0.5 minus 0.2
that comes up and adjusts our one point
four point nine and all our multipliers
in this manner we keep training the
network with multiple inputs until it is
able to predict with the high accuracy
and you can see here we have a different
a quickly switches from cursive a two
may be more elongated a similarly our
network is trained with the images for B
and C 2 so let's take a look at this
here's a straightforward data sets let's
build a neural network to predict the
outputs given the inputs and so we have
an input 0 we expect
an output a zero we have an input of one
we expect six to equals twelve three
should come out as 18 and four as 24
we're just doing multiples of six if you
take the time to look at it so in our
example we have our input and it goes
into our neural network so this box
represents our neural network one of the
cool things about neural networks is
they're always this little black box
that you kind of train to do what you
want and you really don't have to know
exactly what the weights are although
there are some very high-end setups to
start looking at those weights and how
they work and what they do and then you
get your output which is going to be in
this case our inputs going to be X and
our output is going to be Y and W is the
weight so we have value times the weight
so if we're doing in this case just a
single neuron going through we have x
times W the network starts training
itself by choosing a random value for W
we're gonna guess that W equals three
just roll the dice randomly generate the
number three for W and then we put W
equals three in here we have our input
zero or output zero W equals three
equals zero so we have no error on the
first line that actually comes out
correct and then we have one times we
put the one in we're looking for a six
but we get a three instead and we put
the two in we're looking for a 12 we get
a six and set so you can see here our
predicted output doesn't match the what
we're looking for and then we take this
we have our W equals three and we come
up with the second model where the W
equals six now we're gonna look at how
we figure out W equals six in just a
minute that is part of the math behind
this but you can see here we put in W
equals six and we build the W equals six
chart we end up with 0 6 12 18 24 which
is the output we're looking for and in
that manner we end up with the correct
answer but we'll go ahead and put in a
third model where W equals 9 so at this
point this is one way of doing this is
just to guess what W equals and you can
see what W equals 9 we get the incorrect
answers we get 9 18 27 36 we as humans
can know just by taking a look at the
data that our weight should be 6 but how
does the machine come to this conclusion
how do we program the computer to learn
instead of waiting for us to tell it it
has the right answer with the correct
answer is and you can imagine this is a
very simple problem if we're doing
guessing W equals three we guess W
equals six we guess W equals nine and we
look at our results we go oh it's got to
be W equals six that's the best result
but as humans we want to take that
element out and have the computer do
that for us so with that we're gonna
have a loss function the loss function
is a measure of error which defines the
precision lost to comparing the
predicted output to the actual output
and it's simply a loss equals actually
output minus predicted output and then
we square the whole thing so let's apply
the loss function to the input value to
loss for our actual output predicted
output squared and our loss function for
the input of two we end up with an
actual output of 12 and you can see here
where W equals three 12 minus 6 squared
equals 36 so we end up with a loss of 36
W equals 6 12 12 times 12 squared equals
12 minus 12 squared equals 0
or 12 minus 18 squared equals 36 and so
you can see we have a huge loss on W
equals 3 and W equals 9 we now plot a
graph for the weight versus loss and it
always helps to have a nice visual of
what's going on here so this graphical
method of finding the minimal of a
function is called radiant descent and
this is the logic behind this you can
see as we come in here and we go ahead
and graph the loss we have 36 4 3 and 36
4 9 we happen to guess 6 which was the
correct answer right in the middle and
you can see right here forms a nice
little parabola and you can see a nice
mark right in the middle and as a human
being we can look at that we go up the
answer 6 a random point on this curve is
chosen and the slope at this point is
calculated so now we're getting in way
from the human aspect of just looking at
it and saying what the answer is and we
look at what's going on with the math
and so if you have a positive slope it
in case an increase in the weight and a
negative slope indicates a decrease in
weight this time the slope is negative
hints another random point towards its
left is chosen and you can see here
we're actually kind of just playing a
little high-low game going back and
forth with the gradient descent we
continue checking slopes at various
points in this manner so we have our
input actual output W 3 w 6 w 9 we found
our positive slope increase an increase
in weight an eight
slope indicates a decrease in weight a
zero slope indicates the appropriate
weight so our aim is to reach a point
where the slope is zero and when we talk
about neural networks
you're usually processing a massive
amount of information and data so you're
not gonna have all your data nice and
neat where it's just a multiple of six
it's gonna be messy and so we're gonna
keep approaching that number but you'll
never get everything to fit at zero
you're gonna get stuff all over the
place and so you're really looking for
the minimum value
you're not looking for word absolute
zero you're not gonna get it unless
we're talking about gradient descent
that's what we're talking about on there
is finding the bottom of that curve even
if it doesn't go all the way to zero so
how do we apply that to our neural
network well we use back propagation
back propagation is a process of
updating weights of the network in order
to reduce the error in prediction and so
the magnitude of loss of any point on
our graph
combined with the slope is fed back to
the network and you can see here here's
our simple model with just one node of x
times W the input comes in we have our x
times W the output and then we're gonna
propagate that loss going the other way
a random point on the graph gives a lost
value of 36 with a positive slope and we
continue checking slopes at various
points in this manner so a random point
in the graph gives a lost value of 36
with a positive slope 36 is quite a
large number this means our current
weight needs to change by a large number
a positive slope indicates that the
change of the weight must be positive
similarly another random point on the
graph gives a lost value of 10 with a
negative slope 10 is a small number
hence the weight requires to be tuned
quite less a native slowed indicates
that the weight needs to be reduced
rather than increased after multiple
iterations of back propagation our
weights are assign the appropriate value
you can see here we have our input we
just looked at x times 6 and our output
eventually we get it that the weight is
6 for the single node problem that we're
working on right now at this point our
network is trained and can be used to
make predictions let's now get back to
our first example and see where the
backpropagation in gradient descent fall
into place and you can see here we're
not looking at a single node anymore now
we have 28 by 28 grid or 784 and
what's coming into the first level which
has 784 nodes
depending on how you build your neural
network the next layer might also have
784 nodes or I might continually small
and depending on what you need and
what's needed for that to work so as
mentioned earlier our predicted output
is compared against the actual output
and you can see our error over here
actual minus prediction and then we go
ahead and compute our loss
so the loss of a is 0.7 squared equals
0.49 loss of B is 0.5 squared or 0.25
and so on so now we have our first
iteration on there so weights throughout
the network are adjusted in order to
reduce the loss in prediction of course
we do that by doing a second iteration
coming through with our different losses
on there and then we throughout the
network are just in order to reduce the
loss of prediction again underneath the
second and we do a third iteration and
we just keep doing these iterations
going back until we get the right value
now you got to remember that when we're
doing a reverse propagation we're not
looking at just one letter A we're
looking at hundreds of letter a's and
usually we propagate that loss going
backwards we only take a small piece of
it so our adjustments are very small
because one of them is not correct we
don't want to create a bias so we talk
about back propagation we're talking
about going through over and over and
over this data until we get minimal loss
for our letter A so let's focus on the
minimum loss for our variable a and you
can see here we look at that we end up
we'll assume for below to be our graph
for the loss of prediction with the
variable a as compared to the waist
continuing it from the second layer and
we have our loss of a 449 416 4.04 and
you can see it makes this nice curve
where we can guess where the bottom of
this curve is and I like it on this
graph that they show that the curve
doesn't rest yeah on the x-axis it
doesn't rest at where y equals zero
because you usually don't get that you
don't get a perfect fit on anything or
very rarely to ever get a perfect fit
and so the random points chosen on the
graph is now back propagated through the
network in order to adjust the weights
so we're able to go back through the
network and readjust those weights until
we find that minimal value the network
is run once again with the new weights
this process is repeated multiple times
till provides accurate predictions the
weights are further just if I adjust it
to identify B
and see - and this is interesting
because you actually do them at the same
time so as the error goes back you kind
of find the overall error for all the
inputs coming in and then that's what
gets propagated going back or the
overall loss kind of have to step away
from that word error because it's not
just about the error it's about the loss
the weights are further adjusted to
identify B and C - and so a lot of times
you actually do them all at the same
time but you'll adjust those weights a B
and C as I was just saying thus through
gradient descent and back propagation
our network is completely trained and
we've taught it to identify a B and C
coming forward one of the interesting
things about neural networks is the
training process takes a lot longer than
the predicting process so you can plan
one of these training neural networks
doing the back propagation to
significantly longer because you're
going over thousands of data points and
then when you actually run a forward
it's very quick which makes these things
very useful and just really part of
today's world in computing I do want to
thank you today for joining us for more
information visit www.gfi.com/webmonitor
watch similar videos standard up and get
certified
click here